по на 2 sim води нду водиться чика ти в
кілометрових транспортних заторів тем
хто хоче за вишиті донецьк
c один з небагатих на маршруті всищи
відкритих для населення і до нас ага це
доброта сяду підконтрольних києву
територій всім у мережу протікати
веселий контрольно-пропускний пункт
батька забираючи багата годині додому швидше
бути зуму page вище і хочеться щоб все
було пак ворогові лівана правильно на по
дну що страви стояв його так року і
нам xp на жарі склич чай не поїздки
гілки дані роду чаю покупкою
продуктивні доступні в зоні конфлікту
такі зад ринку ви кликаєте бюро не
таке відчуття начебто спеціально це
вираз не бути спеціально ті роблять
чим ряду подавилася їх цілющою в
україні
вона стрибає як думати там з росією з
росією багатих ту критику і складні
беру коротич ній процеси
за право джині українську володіємо
документ це ричерітельно перевіряють а
видно давно ще й автобусні рейси та
теми можна було дістатися за мої сезони
конфлікт з casuals донецьких транспортних
витрат та цін на балу їх ним рішенням
інформації не офіційних даних нам
ніхто не давав тут наносимо ще рук
перекрито за фактом автобуси за чолом
президенту мучити управляє здолає за
видну розкладу тож самий за розкладом
їх вшанував і power that i на сьогодні
автобус із донецька відправляють сили США
до місця в мишах контрольовані
сепаратистам та території талону премку
Росії втомимося годиною у донецьку так вже
шлюбу я хворому даний багатій заправок
та система справний запас стояти довго
chery automobile
зараз же у нас за розряди у нас g3
опресовується дати його теж she
заправляємо їх на мага і масти повний бак
залиті та каністру ще протри метелик
набагато довше влада упакованих
територій у Донецьк дізнаватися про проблеми
з транспортом українську владу
лаві та в створі блокаду за словами з
апарати стив цілий 6 більше з ближче і
їх з росією після пункту поставок
продуктів з України наповнити їх
супермаркетів переважно російські
товари
адже покупки може заплатити і рублям
і алла ви бірма
за необ'їздний свіже молоко дефіцит
Крім цих відсіків палаті зовсім
пустіше таким чином люди у зоні
конфлікту за лише не біда допомога та
приходить зобнин проте при будь аванта
роззява червоного христа також
кориться через пропускний контроль а
поки конфлікт між вам а струнам і
трава і розум і тому лінії контролю
навряд чи пофарбувати і по три з'явиться у
за родом мирне населення